of it is based on being properly
informed about the process you're going
through and so that you can come to a
informed decision I feel like
um from my experience
um having an abortion when I was 19 I
wasn't properly informed like
abortion is something that is classified
as a medical procedure
and with most medical procedures that
you do have and I've had a few
um in my lifetime
um nothing severe but you are informed
about what the procedure is going to be
you are informed about you've shown
images of what you're going to have done
and I feel like abortion is sidelined oh
yeah it's not you don't you're not
properly informed no so for me my
experience I came out the other side and
there was a lot of mental trauma
um and there was a lot of healing there
was a lot of healing process and the
support I think is very important if you
do decide to have an abortion
um as it was in my case and I didn't
feel like I had that at that time and
just to go back to what ruby was saying
um about your your family situation
there's a guy I can't remember his name
and he's literally he was born without
no limbs like he has no arms no legs and
he was actually and he's on YouTube he's
a big YouTuber and I mean his life is
phenomenal and it's going back again
where where what does happiness look
like how do we define happiness he's in
this world and he's impacting this world
and like Leaps and Bounds and he was
born that way he did mention that when
he was I think it was 10 or 12 that he
wanted to commit suicide I can't
remember what he stated what got him
over that hurdle but he's still here
today and he's living he's living a
fulfilled life do you know what I mean
so I think it's it's about having the
right support it's about being well
informed
um and um
yeah I just feel that there is other
options do you know what I mean having
the right mentality yes definitely is
key to life definitely definitely um but
yeah I I must go back on that as well
what you just said um I've had an
abortion myself and again they they
don't really inform you of the procedure
they will say okay yeah you get a pill
and then or you get the vacuum and then
that's it but actually when when I did
get the pill and they said it's all
going to come out don't worry you know
and it will come out and it was a little
baby you know and it's like whoa I
wasn't ready for that you know and it
was just it was shocking you got you got
the pill I got the the pill yeah so how
does that I I know
um once it's surgical they like pull off
the limbs and then vacuum yeah but I
don't I don't actually know as much
about the pill so so the pill so you get
like a couple of them right
um and the like first it wasn't even
like I felt something was stuck so I had
to go go back there and they had to like
take out with a and what's it called
them
four soaps yeah yeah that was my first
um abortion and I had a second one and
um it was it was a pill and you know and
um I decided to go ahead and it was the
worst experience ever because they they
did not inform me that a whole child
would come out of there you know and I
would think it would be in part so I
wouldn't see it you know and it was a
full little child it was the size of my
palm but it was such a horrible
experience you know and I've seen it I I
seen it and that mental picture again
you have to train your mind to forget
that you can't you know when people go
through abortions and they have PTSD
from it I say like the best thing you
can do is to there's ways to forget
about it ways to never think about it
again ways to sort of you know erase
that from your memory but but they don't
tell you anything like that they never
did and I always tell the women you know
that go for abortions are just just
telling you this is what it is you know
and they're like oh really you know and
then they come back like I regret it so
much you know but yeah they should be
more informative 100 how far along were
you I I was like four weeks you're only
four no sorry no that uh this um escape
the when the when the baby came out yeah
oh that one was about
six or eight weeks something really so
six or eight weeks and because they they
say it's like a feed like a clump of
cells basically yeah it was awful baby
and it was like the site it had arms it
had legs it had a head and it was intact
so it wasn't like wow and it wasn't like
it was parts of it it was literally
all of it and and so um because I I've
what I understand about the pill and you
guys you two know more than I do about
this but it's like basically it starves
the kid to death right and then did
like where did it happen at the hospital
or were you at home uh no so this
happened at the hospital yeah so you
take one at home and then like you said
I didn't know it would stop the child
right so but yeah you take one at home
then you come I think it's the next day
or in two days and then you have another
pill and it's meant to come out of you
and whatnot well and it is does it
always come out at the hospital if you
do the pills I think some people have
done it at home and it they just it goes
down the toilet you know oh okay that's
what they say so since the pandemic
um basically they allowed they changed
the law to allow these abortion pills to
be sent by post to people's homes which
causes all sorts of issues because many
women don't know how far along they are
so you're only meant to have the pills
up to about 10 weeks and um you know
there's been stories of people having it
at 12 13 14 15 weeks and ended up in
hospital and hemorrhaging and things
like that and so yeah just being sent
and they yeah they're literally saying
the instructions to flushed the baby or
the products of conception down the
toilet so yeah I'm sorry you had to see
that that must have been no sorry like
you have to sort of oh my God over that
I do not know wow yeah um do you want to
show the video I actually have not seen
this video I don't know what it is
what do you think about abortion each
individual is up to them what they want
to do I think everybody should be around
them right I'm not really foreign or
against you everyone has their right to
kind of do what they call is right in
their own life so what I want to show
now is a short one minute video of what
an abortion procedure looks like at
various stages from 10 to 24 weeks
[Music]
of two things to do now
no way
sorry I didn't know I could do it yeah
I'm sorry I can't look at it
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
so that's the video
those babies are finished it wasn't even
like it was they had hands I didn't know
I was like that that's a body that's a
shoe that's a whole lot of full grown
man it's fully developed
that [ __ ] I really shouldn't be right
that's technically even though the baby
may not be out as technically I'll
relate that to murder
people no
[Music]
I'm a bit speechless actually it is a
person and people don't realize that a
lot of people think oh is this a bunch
of cells in that to the point but you
know three months and on you can really
see the formation and everything so as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible